each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
grasses most sting wishing feature is
that he's actually my successor at the
University of Wisconsin so when I left
to come to Microsoft rafts followed me
into the University of Wisconsin and
then did some great work there and moved
to Berkeley and is now doing great work
at Berkeley and grass is visiting us for
three days will be here in ms are so if
anybody wants to talk to him you should
get in touch with her ass and make some
arrangements to talk with him Rask thank
you so I haven't been here for a while
which is it is because I didn't feel I
have enough stuff that's cool enough to
show you but I think we have another
interesting result the divers presenting
here and what I'll talk about today is
our work on synthesis synthesis by
sketching which is a project that has
two efforts in it and i'll talk about
both of these efforts today and so the
top may take a few minutes over an hour
but the good news is that it only takes
two slides to give you the key message
the first slide compares sketching with
the other two traditional approaches for
getting software correct and writing it
productively the first is verification
in which you write two things you write
a specification of the intended behavior
the functional spec and then you write
also the program the low-level program
and then verification checks that the
specification and the implementation are
consistent there is sort of redundancy
there because you first write the spec
and then we also implement the program
in a lower level language and you check
for their consistency so you're writing
two things and this redundancy has been
recognized by people who do synthesis
and what they propose is that well why
don't we just ride the spec ideally
declaratively rather than interactively
and then generate the code that does
what we intend and so if this sounds too
good to be true it's the case and you in
fact could say that you fool didn't they
tell you about set L and in fact they
did tell me about so tell so this is
synthesis is not what we are going to
do but instead will do synthesis of it
sketching which is sort of synthesis the
difference is that the spec at least in
our current instance is executable which
is good because it's easy to debug and
then the programmer sketches the
outlines of the desired implementation
sort of to guide the synthesizer so that
the synthesizer doesn't do the damn
naive thing but they actually generates
code that's good in the way the
programmer votes and so this is what
sketching is the second slide shows the
programmer experience it's catching the
intended one at please so the programmer
writes the sched of the desired
implementation and then the
implementation is a completed sketch
with all the hairy details and the
synthesizer of course doesn't have a
basis for knowing what the hairy detail
should be so of course there is a spec
and it is this sketching equations in
quote that describes the entire effort
and i'll talk about two efforts and the
first one sort of follows the vanilla
approach in which will have a spec will
have a sketch which is the desired
implementation and outline and then the
implementation is provided so the first
effort that try sketching on the domain
of bit streaming for crypto programs and
this is an interesting case study
because this domain is getting more and
more interesting it spans from Krypto to
coding to code breaking and it's
interesting because there is a big
implementation guide the difference
between the spec and the implementation
itself is huge you can often describe
ciphers in a few lines of code because
you can do it at the level of bits but
the actual implementation the talks at
the level of words the sort of parallel
version of the cipher is often very
different than the spec or much larger
or both it's also an interesting because
in this domain both performance is
critical obviously because on servers up
to ninety five percent of cycles can
spend time in crypto thing of encoding
pages with SSL and correctness is of
course crucial because small mistakes
can make it possible to break a large
number of key
this has happened in the past so the
running example that you'll go through
this case study is a very simple cipher
if you will it drops the third bit from
every street it's hardly a cipher but it
has the properties of other cipher
surprisingly it's a there is a big
implementation guide as you will see and
there are many different possibilities
on how to implement it's more like a
parity dropping off of a bit rather than
cipher but a thing of it however you
like so there is one way of how to
implement this running example and
that's taking two bits from a word and
compacting it by shifting them so each
of these steps will be probably three
machine instructions and end and a shift
and an order there is a better way which
is logarithmic in the word size and
scotlock shifting here we have more
parallelism because we shift more bits
at once at the cost of shifting some
bits multiple times so it's harder to
implement this version of the bit
shifting but in our approach we can
sketch that faster implementation we
start by the functionality which is what
the piece of code should do it should
compact the bits to the beginning of the
word dropping every third and now the
programmer provides the schedule
visually can be represented like that
what does the sketch say the sketch says
only what the programmer has in mind the
program says it looks like I could
implement this functionality which needs
to be decomposed into machine
instructions in three steps in first
step I shipped some bits by one which is
what this ? say in the second Sun beats
by two in the for third some bits by
four and I don't know which bits I need
to shift to implement it and in fact I
don't care whether this implementation
strategy works to implement this desired
functionality it doesn't care because
the system the synthesizer will put
these two together and if the strategy
can be used then an implementation will
be provided if the strategy doesn't
implement this bit permutation which may
happen if the bits cross then the system
will say sorry I cannot help you and so
this is how we avoid bugs
in providing sort of high-performance
implementation of your functionality so
for this example actually you need two
sketches the one that I showed you is
this one in the language that we use
here is another one which shows how to
pack bits into words so we the first one
talks about bits videon works the second
one well it beats outside the word so
you don't need to understand it but this
is the program sort of that it generates
at what we want to remember is that
compared to having no sketch at all
these five lines of a sketch provide
significant speed up a very good
implementation which gets better as the
machine gets wider of course to give you
an eye ok so compare that with hundred
plus lines of Fortran which is actually
an existing implementation of a similar
benchmark another example of what you
can do with sketches more realistic one
comes from the DA's cipher there is a
permutation that flips around 64 bits
and you cannot easily implement it well
efficient leave it standard and then or
operations because there is too much
irregularity here so the programmer
needs to do a trial and error to find
those implementations and the one that
will sort of work well is using a table
so you take some bits from the input 64
bits and you index tables and this is
how you do probably these tables could
be too large even after this trick and
so what the programmer does and that's
sort of the approach with sketching that
he stares at the permutation and see
there is some level of regularity there
and he decomposes the permutation into
two stages he sketch is the first one
which is very simple it can be
implemented effectively advance shift
and an or and he doesn't specify the
second one the system will synthesize
and maybe to the programmer surprise
these permutations here will be now much
simpler they are narrower 32 bits and
they identical so the tables you need to
implement them now are four times
smaller and therefore regular space
which makes a big difference on some
machines
so I think there are two messages on
this slide the first one is that you see
that sketch is sometimes and code
implementation intentions that an
optimizer or synthesizer however you
wanna call it would have a hard time
finding except for searching the entire
space of possibilities which seems too
large at least in this domain second you
need a trial and error to find a good
implementation and this is the sketch is
a convenient way of doing it because I
just stayed what I want the first stage
to do and let the system figure out what
the second stage should be or tell me
that the strategy doesn't work
preventing me from introducing a bug by
sketching the programmer actually draws
that figure on the left now there
actually is a language in standard text
syntax in say that so in this
would be a fragment or it effectively
this is the whole thing which this is
the sketch and the sketch for the second
stage is empty which is to say that the
system will synthesize it so that the
second these two permutations together
implement the original
based on knowing that this is sort of
our specification this is the behavior
we want to implement now we are looking
for a better implementation of this
functionality similar to the spec and
the better implementation will first do
this simple presentation followed by one
that's irregular but smaller so the
system will synthesize the second stage
so that these two together implement
what you saw before the 64 bit to 64 bit
fermentation great
well this is where his inside needs to
come in and this is where you need to do
trial and error and do it fast which is
why sketching help so if you look at it
you see well there is some regularity
here and so let me try to do a first
stage that's cheap to implement that
does that and maybe something good will
come out maybe not you need to come up
with a different schedule so go back to
the previous slide so yes so fact you're
not showing us the spec is it actually
pretty even know this is the spec no no
internet porn well the text respect for
this would be one big array which tells
you where that little bit ladder you can
imagine terrorists to now it's just
imitations our bed I could show it to
you about the other not sure is so you
don't have to write it in this exact you
saying it's actually very good very good
so these figures here is my programming
language for the sake of next 60 minutes
but see you have to write the that
program that sketch program and you also
have to give this back right which is
that table whole thing that's right
that's right so you remember that
equation right you need to have a spec
which is the behavioral thing and then
the sketch is sort of outline of the
structure of how you actually implement
that behavior
and so this is the spec and now this is
the outline of the implementation this
is the completed implementation from so
this will mean it seems like it's
probably impossible for a sketch to
defeat the spam in other words if I give
us back there's no way for me to also
give a sketch that will somehow mean
that no algorithm can be synthesized how
it is possible how it is part yes so if
you come back here to this one so this
log shifter cannot implement all
possible permutations if some bits
crossed here they could end up at some
stage in the same position overwriting
each other so then what feedback do I
get as a programmer if I've done that
what's it look like to me that we didn't
figure that out fully this is an
important part of any sketching system
right so yeah that's a research question
so far we will tell you where bits over
it and sort of give you a constraint
that cannot be satisfied but
it's far from us being happy belated yes
so feedback is an important thing
so this is the programming experience so
how does it actually all works we need
to start with the specification which is
the language in which you enter the
program and so it's an executable
specification you can run it and in the
language here in the PowerPoint it's
just that it takes three bits from the
input stream drops the third one the
programmers actually you stream it and
this is what this filter looks at is
dreaming in in work each work cycle it
takes three bits pushes out to such that
it drops the third one and pushes supers
internally these filters are represented
as matrices which valued in a three
input bits to output bit and this row
tells you that in the first position on
the output there will be the first bit
from the input the semantics is one of
matrix multiplication you take the three
bits from the input stream multiply the
matrix you get a vector that is for the
push on beale
now we are ready to stay the problem of
how to do the sketching Bay syntheses
you have a spec now you have a sketch of
the implementation now the problem is
this we want to synthesize a program for
some target machine that behaves like
that but this implement is structurally
like that somewhere inside now even that
problem is sort of still fuzzy so I'll
take you to the solution to the problem
through several simpler steps the first
step will be having no sched whatsoever
now the problem is simply taking the
spec and compiling it for the target
machine and the problem is simplified by
the observation that any implementation
we have in mind over machine
instructions such as shifts and an arse
corresponds to a dataflow program where
each of these filters implement this
instruction so this one is a shift and
can be represented with the matrix and
so this is a dataflow program that
represents the target machine a target
program a program that you can directly
emit in to see they call these programs
implementation programs and so now the
baseline compiler which is one that
doesn't accept any sketch works over a
space of these data flow programs now
some of them are implementations which
is all filters are worth size and
correspond to machine instructions this
can be directly translated to see and
then there are those that are not in
that form but can be pushed into that
poor see if I give you a spec which is
not an implementation I have a bunch of
other programs that are functionally
identical to it but structurally
different and these are more decomposed
than others in the sense that we have
translated this program through the
composition of filters into program that
contains only machine instructions and
we do it by defining a function rewrite
function that takes any program and
decomposes into lower level
and if you apply sequence of these rare
right rules we always end up in a
program that only contains machine
instructions and is sort of rewritable
to see so for that spec this is the past
that the compiler would follow in a
greedy fashion to get us an
implementation not very good but one
that you can run facial how do you
guarantee tribulation because the
program is always sort of simpler
monotonically and it terminates let me
show you what these steps are for this
domain let's assume a 4-bit machine and
here is the filter of our running
example the first step we do the unroll
it so that on the input and on the
output its word size multiple other
birds and we split the filter this way
so that we obtain three filters such
that each reads the size of a word and
we split them like that and be obtained
a dataflow program where each filter I
didn't split these two reads in a word
and output a work to see just unroll
chop it like this chop it like that now
he averts eyes filters these don't
correspond to machine instructions yet
but you can decompose it into a filter
that is over machine instructions and
you can generate a program out of it so
it see this monotonic the composition
because this is a filter that reads a
word but outputs two words now if you're
in search engine area convert a
Stratasys solutely so you don't need to
understand details of what happens here
but you see how you would rewrite it so
this is our simple algebra rewrite rules
that in a greedy way gives you some
implementation and so these are the
instructions now the second problem that
gets us closer to sketching synthesis is
one where the programmer provides a
fragment of an implementation so this is
not a sketch right the program are
specified exactly what these steps
should be there is nothing left
ambiguous here no non determinism now
how does the compiler incorporate this
programmers idea this log shifting into
the compilation process well in two
steps first the compiler figures out
what is the functionality that this
implements and you just collapse it and
you realize oh this is what the
programmer met and now in the baseline
compilation process when the compiler
encounters a filter that looks like this
that has this functionality it will be
replaced with this pipeline of filters
so there it will be simple rewrite rule
guided by the programmer so here we
decompose decompose and if at some point
there is a filter in the program that
looks like this behavior it will be
replaced to what the programmer gave and
so will nudge the compiler to go here
and then the greedy translation will
follow so we combine the human insight
with both the naive compiler the
baseline compiler does and so the only
other I did when the compiler doesn't do
a good job and we end up with a better
implementation
so sorry so there's a pattern match that
goes on and all that the user provides
is real I close the circle then it seems
like you know you can use a controller
instead of them and more than one to be
applicable it's what you are saying
seems like really non deterministic
algorithm so yes so currently what we
have is we need to provide little bit
more than just the rewrite rule we need
to also specify where in that hierarchy
of filters in the heart of data for
program those rules apply
now to make it better to avoid the need
for specifying where those rewrite rules
may and may not apply we need to do some
analysis to guarantee termination not
that the museum is fine as long as we
end up in the same position but to avoid
cycles we need to do some more analysis
and that's something we haven't done yet
actually think of the sketch form is a
rewrite rules depends there are
different sketches and some of them you
can think of sort of rewrite rules
perhaps the best way is to will get to
skype soon and sink them will get back
your fish but the fact that yes this
process good cycle is a problem and
currently they have we have a solution
that could be improved significantly get
some analysis that guarantees that we
sort of strongly minimize the program so
before you say you're coming for a 4
dead 2 shape right but it's the the
sketch that this rewrite will each scale
as was on 32-bit it was on 16 bits we
will resolve the problem here so so
you're saying it doesn't have to match
it actually does have to match it does
actually provide a sketch for forbidden
yes but that's an easy thing to change
since you can have symbolic variables in
those but here is the inconsistency
right here is our what the baseline
compiler would do up to this step and
I'm showing here the process on four
bits because I wanted to make the matrix
is manageable but here I'm showing you a
visual language for 16 bits but pretend
that this is 16 bits and all will make
sense so at this point the programmer
have provided the photo recipe not a
sketch and what happened is that the
compiler realized oh this filter here
actually implements that and I'm
supposed to rewrite it with this so this
will be replaced with a pipeline of
three filters and then further rewritten
into target machines instructions
so now we are ready to show how the
sketch is incorporated into it so now
the sketch corresponds not to a single
filter with a single functionality but
to many different ones depending on
whether you shift the bit or you let it
be copied done and so what happens is
the idea is the same we go down and each
step we check every filter and see can
it be implemented with the sketch any vs
very right and so what happens with you
again nagy the compiler and override its
default naive rule to the one provided
by the programmer and the way you do it
is that this is the space of all
possible programs that the schedule
describes and from them we choose one
that is functionally identical to this
one to preserve semantics how does the
programmer know whether their schedules
use in
so right now we expect that it will be
used and it's not used without the
programmer that we failed please but
again a better Diagnostics is needed
them that's part of the research
question so so if you find a solution
that doesn't use a sketch then you go
back and try to find another basically
ah yes exactly is the sketch presumably
it was because it didn't apply is there
is there any way to know that you're
going in the right direction to use the
sketch in other words or is it just
improves your route for search so what
is so usually when the program our
programs with sketches he understands
that this is what the program looks like
a particular stage of the decomposition
you know so you know if you look back at
this example here the programmer has an
idea of how the program looks like after
you split the filters like that and like
that and so he knows which part of the
program and which level of the
composition he wants to over and so he
can examine actually this sequence and
see whether the sketch applied here or
not that seems like too much work but
you need to understand what happens
currently in real life all these
programs the target programs are eaten
by hand and the program's needs to keep
track of all this and now we are getting
rid of it a lot of it and bring them
from any details and providing
correctness as well yes so but the
issues of how to best tell the
programmer of a vendor reschedule I and
why didn't when he didn't we don't have
satisfactory answers here can I think of
sketches as being somewhat like
old-fashioned compiler hints like the
register keyword and see or the inline
keyword and C++ where I kind of know
what the compiler is going to do when it
compiles the code and so I give it a
hint at a particular point that this
local should be registered this is now
you can think of it as a hint except as
a strong hand in the sense that we need
to follow that sketch the programmer
cannot the compiler cannot ignore it so
the way to think of the the way to thing
of the sketch is as a non-deterministic
program right so what's going on here is
we have one program that is simple but
not very efficiently and then we have
another program that is behaviorally
identical but structurally very
different
and it's a pain to write it so what I do
I write a program that is
non-deterministic in the center didn't
codes many possible executions and one
of them were more than one of them
corresponds to the behavior that i
started demanding expect and the fact
that i can make it non deterministic
means that i can eliminate many details
that choose a particular execution and
this non determinism is removed by
sketch resolution so the best way to
think of sketch is as we have one
programs simple slow it's your
behavioral stack another one that the
rewrites it but doesn't provide all the
details be sort of completed to behave
like that but be implemented fast
actually slightly different
but we don't have an implementation yet
that actually can resolve a sketch that
this is written as a non-deterministic
program currently these sketches are it
and I saw the rewrite
so so the sketch is not very different
than what we had before except it in
code the space of programs and out of
those we choose one that is identical to
the one that we re writing now how is
this done it's very simple because we
come here to a filter whose behavior is
indicated here and now we resolve it
such that we obtain this this this
program which is not non-deterministic
and we replace it here now semantically
it's all done using matrix algebra all
these filters are represented as
matrices and so the decomposition of
this filter into a 5-line of multiple
filters is matrix factorization so when
these three matrix is multiplied to be
this matrix we have guaranteed
correctness of this decomposition sort
of guarantees our property that we don't
introduce bugs now what does the sketch
do the sketch introduces some
constraints that these factors these
three matrices which are these three
steps must follow in this case we say
that this first factor must shift bids
from 1 to 16 either by zero or by one
bit and similar for the other factors so
the resolution of the sched is searching
for a matrix decomposition that gives us
this and also satisfies the constraints
on these factors a question that vector
on the left hand side of this is its
size node yes so select 32 or 64
something like that
so this comes from the specification of
the program perhaps after some of those
rewrite rules that were naively done by
the compiler so for example I need to
specify the length of that vector use
your system right for example can i say
that i hope i don't know the length of
the parameter in can we still use your
system not currently seeing at least in
the cipher domain the block sizes and
the sizes of permutations of things but
it's not a problem I see and you're
expected to be a power of two are those
kind of restriction but it may be
possible to extend it such a district
striction two don't apply but then you
probably need a different algebra of
rewrite rules so one thing is we'll
unintuitive so in essence matrix that
one two or three ideally I would
actually want to just do one more matrix
multiplication with that rather than
three with some with these fact remains
right from a optimization point of view
right the only reason you want to do the
decomposition is because it can actually
implement the simpler ones with an
instruction rather than having to have
an actual matrix and do the
multiplication right is that is that
well I should think about it because if
these are general matrices that you can
do a place for them with an instruction
but you have to actually do a matrix
multiplication then I'd rather want to
use em rather than three vigilance right
um
drew but the reason why you decompose
them is that by decomposing these
matrixes you are really providing higher
level steps of the algorithm
so if I give you these decompositions at
home they're they're useless unless each
individual step and atomization can be
implemented with a simple instruction in
your in your target architecture but
then I got no it works through these
these steps into which I'm decomposing a
program doesn't tell me to be
implementable with a machine instruction
any typically isn't these are not
directly implementable with a single
instruction they need like three
instructions but usually when you do a
decomposition that each of these factors
or filters in the pipeline that you
created will be then decomposed further
with other sketches or perhaps just did
the baseline compiler with the default
sequence or rewrite rules so the way to
think about it is that this is sort of
the algorithm you need to implement and
to do it well you need to think of some
high-level steps of how to proceed and
here is one decomposition into
high-level steps it seems to be working
really well because it gets a lot of bit
lower powers and just I'm just asking
better the intuition right I mean it's
not clear that that you're going to gain
anything
not clear at all right because if I'm
gonna I can do the operation with one
matrix multiplier it says as a spare out
during right or or okay I feel the exact
conclusion is here you are not actually
using any matrix multiplication to
perform these operations matrix
multiplication is only the semantics for
these big permutations sort of this is
our vehicle for deciding how to actually
be composed a given permutation into
smaller steps no matrix multiplication
will actually be ever performed so if I
know I want to be composite into three
steps that should look like that i can
use the matrix multiplication algebra to
decide what the steps should look like
if they also need to have these
properties triple diamond your your your
search for the program right your
decomposition in the baseline compel
right eventually we will have to admit
some instructions right I me unless it
finds some smart things because the
matrices have some simple form it will
have to emit instructions that
essentially have the same complexity as
the original matrix multiply
there's no magic
to do that right and so clearly if if
you're into position that you're
providing is not going to lead to simple
instructions you will have a three times
complexity now what its cost but still I
mean you're looking for big dollars that
you're worried about okay so plants are
that question if you look at what the
baseline compiler would do with its
default rules on be composing this
matrix it'll overload instruction you
would obtain that slow algorithm which
you may remember on the side that was
linear in the size of the word which was
shifting to bits by two bits so if you
use that approach that algorithm doesn't
have access to the high level view of be
the composition which the programmer has
and if you do something naive so it will
actually have more steps than here
linear inside of the burger today let's
take the all I'm guessing it's just I'm
just wondering about how do you think I
as a programmer I don't really have any
good intuition as to whether mighty
composition is going to help
well it seems that I'm actually making
the problem more complicated exactly so
that's why it's very non local
optimization that's right and so the
sketches don't help you gain that
intuition except iterating faster
through the process by rapid prototyping
and the guarantee that divine introduce
any bugs right the system won't
magically give you the intuition in just
the two floors program cost
give any feedback on how how the new
implementation is better or should I
compile it and run it see currently we
just compile it and running but you can
envision actually counting the number of
instructions or cycles that's sort of a
less interesting problem that they
didn't so what exactly is the meaning
farewell my mom Cavallari in the sketch
spaces all right this says you know
first so so clearly you've got follow
the arrow or don't follow the oh right
so you get 0 or 20 40 all right can I
also do things like the same line so you
could do choose or zeros or for us you
know I see our single set right yes you
could so so can you kind of tell us what
the overall vocabulary there is for
sketches yeah so in the current
implementation the vocabulary is that
you can specify whether the bits should
move by some predator me instead of
constant positions okay or you can say
that all bids need to so that's one
option and other option is all bits in
that word need to move by the same
amount but again you don't determine
what that amount is so this is different
sort of on strength and then there are
two others which I forget we just sort
of simpler version of the tool so you
constrain in various ways how bits and
and which gives your ship damaged of
don't bill staples built-in media some
of them that you have the option
objective but the vocabulary you should
think of as a particular constraint on
the current system that sort of virgin 0
forged I should really thing in and
sketch as a non-deterministic program
that can follow various executions
depending on some conditions that are
like star conditions in
non-deterministic some limits some
limitations but something doesn't and so
that's sort of the vocabulary for the
sketch that thing of the sched is a
program that can take various executions
and the problem of resolving the sketch
is one of finding an execution that
implements the thing on the left
so is it that
you matrix algebra to result in his cage
no we use them to resolve these sketches
which are most views for these
decomposition sketches which take a
filter decompose it into a pipeline just
to the big question what exactly does
this matrix and
the matrix M is an internal
representation in the compiler of this
filter of this deep permutation so this
whole thing works Mac increased
factorizations very specific to this
kind of a filter celebrate it's not
particular to make and to the particular
sketch where you take a filter and break
it down into a pipeline of stages ok so
in this domain you say that that is true
that is you know if if you have a
decomposition which is a matrix fact
that's right so in other domains the
algebra may be very different and we
don't know yet what it should look like
but there have been a lot of work on
optimizing paralyzing compilers which
have similar algebra
a composition of
in the sense that it falls into the
baseline compilation process and yes so
so actually resolving the sketches
technically the most interesting part of
the talk but I think what is the most
novel is the approach of finding a way
of specifying what implementation we
want so to evaluate what we tried we
tried for experiments the first we
wanted to see that the programmers can
actually write this specification or
called reference solutions in the new
language in the streaming language and
we wanted to see how well the base
compiler does performance wise on these
programs can they be compared with Henry
fancy then we saw how much sketching can
help in improving the performance and
then compared our ciphers with Pantene
handwritten programs so what we did we
took a bunch of programmers have them
developed a small cipher in C and in the
stream in language and measure the time
it took them to do it so there are four
programmers that finished in stream bit
and five that finished in C and it took
those programmers its trim bit the last
time on average than those in see even
though stream it is not the best
language for writing those ciphers
because they have unusual data for
structure the paths cross and that's
quite hard to encode in stream it
what was it a little past here soon as
they have to get a final program out and
then run it and then be assured that it
did the right thing yes and in the case
of C programmers which is the sort of
second experiments we allow them to
continue until the performance so we
come back here we wanted to see what the
performance was over time so the
streamit programmers developed the first
version they were done and this is the
time and some C programmers continued
and improve the performance in some
cases significantly but it was still
almost three times less then the
baseline compared with no sketches did
on our solutions from the thing the dose
fingered program is other knowledge but
what kind of sketches be appropriate
index for that problem they didn't but
they didn't do any sketching at this
point so that didn't hurt them the only
thing they were supposed to do is
develop a working solution so they'd
recommend a sketch to be used and now
they didn't us the idea is that some
other expert will come later and take
their solutions and sketch a better
implementation for them in a sort of
decomposition between a domain expert a
trip to experiment performance expect
yeah they oh yeah they did get the sort
of tutorial on what optimizations you
may wanna do on these ciphers and some
of them try to implement them but they
were hard to do in a short amount of
time because they required a lot of
rewriting of the code so then we took
the worst of these implementations and
we'd sketching on them and see in a time
of over about four hours the performance
improved about three times it was
because you can very quickly write
sketches and get feedback on performance
and which of them actually work
semantically and improve the performance
we had another guy a sea expert
implement the cipher now taking as much
time as he was able to bear and provide
a good implementation in C and he got up
to here so the sketched one is twice as
fast and about fifty percent faster
finally we compared an implementation of
D years we'd leave d as each we believe
the best publicly available portable
diaz version and on 32-bit machine we
are about seventeen percent slower in
the worst case on pentium three and we
can overcome it when we make the
sketching more general and we were
actually faster on 64-bit machines yes
so how long did it take to develop your
implementation your recording numbers
for you
once the spec was done I think it was
one afternoon so in one afternoon
Armando did develop maybe six different
implementations by doing six different
sets of sketches so it was very quick
compared to live the years which is
several years of effort with many people
contributing ideas on how to do it he of
course stole the ideas on how to
optimize from them but implemented the
much faster so what what I have shown
you with sketching in this domain you
have separation of estate the
correctness and performance and also
separation of roles you can have domain
experts like creep to experts right this
peg and then somebody else come and
actually provide an implementation
without breaking correctness and also
good to sing why it worked in this
domain there is a big gap between how
concisely can write a cipher and what
the implementation actually looks like
and we could come up with simple algebra
of transformation that made it all
possible it's still open of how should
the sketch program look like and what
the feedback to the programmer should be
but I think as a concept it's a very
strong proof that you can iterate very
quickly and I'm good to get good
solutions because correctness is going
to feel and there are other domains
where these properties I think are
satisfied centric kernels media codecs
graphics somewhere else
the domain value problems so well
understood that you know what
la positions on going on
Oh does this help
so what we mean exactly
into the program and
can call it efficiently notice using
this sketch so there are domains are
perhaps all the conditions are satisfied
but good implementation exists like FF
es perhaps there is no need for a system
like that but did you start working even
in those domains two new machines like
the multi course you may consider
building such a system because it's
faster than building an optimizer a
paralyzing from tyler because you don't
need to train the optimizer to do all
the standard transformations you have
just a set of rewrite rules a way of
sketching and the programmers can sort
of describe what implementation they
want to sort of a very quick way of
writing and optimizing parallelizing
compiler if you will for a DSL but yes
some domains perhaps a salt and they
don't need to be revisited
so at this point it's perhaps good to
philosophize a little bit and talk about
the large implementation gap and it
seems that the large gap exists only
between only the sort of scientific high
throughput programs where performance is
important but if you step back you
actually realize that the implementation
gab is something that goes through
algorithmic research all around right
most research in algorithms is about
obtaining better performance to standard
problems so could you claim that a
binary search tree standard one is a
specification of a red black tree which
you could sketch and so if you think
about the debt way perhaps we could use
sketching in areas that you wouldn't
consider high-performance areas and just
write a simple program that is
executable but is so simple that you
trust it as a specification is
executable you can debug it doesn't use
logic so perhaps it's accessible to
programmers and then sketch the
implementation that sort of improves of
it you sketch the rotation by showing
how just one link rotates the
synthesizer will finish the code that
implements the red black tree skeptical
wasn't that a similar problem that the
people in settle tried I don't know they
tried this automatic data structure
selection maybe they try but see if they
did it's just the proof that may be an
argument for why you need to actually
sketch because we don't rely on being
fully out and I think we let the
programmer specify the hard things and
synthesizer to fill in the details that
guarantee correctness so sort of
programmer synthesizer videos whether we
can pull it off for the pointer
basically not clear but I would claim
there is an implementation get as well
I don't know I would have to ask a month
so but what if there is no
implementation get what if this back
here and the code are pretty measure the
same level of abstraction what if the
spec is hard to write logic there is no
rewrite algebra that you know of can we
still use the idea and what I'll tell
you about next very briefly is a system
where we don't provide any spec a priori
we just sketch the desired
implementation we generate multiple
versions of the completed sketch and
then the program are looking at these
codes will select the desired one sort
of selecting the specification after the
synthesis this is in cases where the
specification is hard to write so Shri
Ram is cringing so try to convince him
there is a reason for doing this I just
don't understand so the thing is that
you sketch the code that you want to
obtain but you don't specify the
behavior it should have it synthesized
several candidates and by looking at the
code you realize oh I know I've on this
one it does have the behavior you want
so the problem here is helped with
Reeves right so the reuse has been known
to be great people wanted to do more
until lampson said well it good luck dad
and said there are really just three
reusable components they have a lot of
functionality under the simple interface
and the rest of the components may be
hard to sell compose and understand but
recently the first two problems have
been solved almost it seems to pay to
give components away for free design
patterns provide connectors for
components but they are still hard to
understand these components because in
order to make a flexible set of
components you need to have small lego
pieces because they are small there will
be many of them so in practice it looks
like this in Eclipse 2.1 I knew there
was an java parser because somebody else
used it so I found the handle to the
Java file of
I file I found the type for the S do you
know then I thought in a few minutes I
will be able to invoke the parser and
get the ASD for the code it took two
hours and the reason why I took so much
is that it's actually very hard task I
ask my students to do it actually they
ran into the problem independently it
also took them two hours so I felt
better about myself but I felt worse
about the reuse and the reasons why it's
so hard is that if you follow expected
designs you're not going to find the
code because you expect one level of
file handles there are two these two red
types you cannot use class browsers
because there are two classes you don't
know about and if you've done a resort
to grab you're not going to find
anything because the method that you
need here parts compilation unit returns
compilation unit type which is a
subclass of ast node so if you are
grabbing for that you are not going to
find this either so this is actually a
good design and convince us that in
other api's will face similar problems
so we decided to sort of attack the
problem since it's not going to go away
and the idea is to have the programmer
express the programming intent and the
system will supply the code that sort of
implements the desired reuse but the
problem we face does the programmer
often doesn't know exactly how to say
what he wants to do often his intent is
as vegas parse my file so to face that
we let the programmer state a partial
intent we synthesize multiple candidate
codes and then the programmer will need
to select from among them it's sort of
like the search engine experience where
you just enter a few keywords and then
from the few candidates you can quickly
select what you intended to look for and
that's faster than actually making the
specification of the keywords more
precise so sort of the burden shifts to
post more than post search or post
synthesis where the problem is easier so
we are ready for a problem statement
here and the problem is that will feed
the synthesizer first some input that
teaches about the API and it will come
first from api declarations and then
from sample client code
I'll talk about it later in the second
half of this fragment of the talk if
there is time and then once we teach it
about the API we can then ask the
programmer for the intent and generate
code that can be directly inserted into
the code being written and the
candidates are ranked so that the
programmer can select from them so now
that the problem is set up somewhat we
can show you three observations that
make it all possible the first one is
somewhat surprising that most these
reviews problems can be specified with a
simple query that is a pair of static
types the first one is have type second
is a bold type and what the clarie says
I have a pointer to an object of some
type and give me the code that results
in a pointer of the one type so sort of
generalized type conversion of you will
so in our example this is the hab type
we have a pointer to this file and we
want to obtain a pointer to an ast node
and this query however loose is usually
actually quite sufficient now there is
another observation about the code that
we need to generate and we call it a
jungle and the jungle is just a chain
expression a unary expression composed
of you near expressions which in the
case of Java fill the excesses instant
methods with zero argument static
methods with one argument and the
conversion to a supertype so here here
is our jungle it is a call to a static
method with one argument and an instant
mess of it well two arguments but this
is a non pointer argument which we
simply ignore because these are easy to
specify later once the code is
synthesized is a sort of configuration
parameters now if the code is not a
jungler that you desire we still can
help you and in fact this is the
powerful mode of views of our generator
if this is the code you need then to the
data flow graph there is a method with
multiple arguments then it really has to
jump loads here and the user would first
generate say this one and leave a free
variable the synthesizer would leave a
free variable which you can then
initialize with synthesizing in a second
invocation of the synthesizer another
John blood so we wanted to see how
general actually this definition is does
it cover it interesting cases we picked
16 reuse problems and fell out of them
could be described with the query so
what's pretty good three quarters and
then out of these that are describable
with the query nine had jungle roads
that were straight junk loads and three
of them required composition of multiple
jungle so repeated invocation of the
synthesizer now once the problem is
defined like that how do we synthesize
androids and at this point because we
took care to state the problem in a very
simple way synthesis becomes trivial we
have a program representation where each
node is a type static class are not that
class that saw a static type and it's
connected with edges that represent this
unit jungler so methods that convert one
pointer to another or widening now given
a query which is a pair of types such as
I file over there and Iceland owed each
path between these two nodes is a jungle
now the problem is with so many jungles
which of them do you actually offer to
the programmer in turns out that usually
the shortest path is the desired Android
at the user bonds among the cash ortus
pass is the code that the programmer
wats in like ninety percent of cases
that we looked at so now the probably
most interesting part from the user
point of view how do we actually make
the synthesizer available to the
programmer and the way we do it is put
it into the code completion that's
standard part of IDEs and so what this
happens in code completion that if the
cursor is here at this point use the
Java type system to determine which
methods or fields are accessible on that
variable file and this is what an ID
would give you a set of methods here
with their help so we sort of overload
that and if this is what the programmer
has written so far and invoke the
synthesizer at this point and we know
that the font type is
steno because we need the value that is
of this type so this is the once type
the have types come from the lexical
scope these our to have types and so
having these two sets of types actually
the one type is always a singleton we
have these two queries which we can then
feed to synthesizer and it will generate
the candidates which we rank and offer
to the programmer like this here is the
various code that be synthesized and
actually you see it contains nested
methods so in one line nested methods
here and here they are broken into two
lines for readability see if you look at
this and step back and think about the
sketching equation what is it that we
have here we have a partial
implementation here which sort of acts
as a sketch and we are looking for ways
to complete the program by synthesizing
several candidates and then the
programmer by seeing the candidates can
easily choose the right one and it's
actually true that the selection is easy
as I'll show you in a demo and then
selecting and choosing the right one
effectively select the desired
specification and I'll show in a demo of
the process works yes so let's say that
you want to get our food okay well it
turns out that the correct way to do it
is good first generate bass from foo
somehow and then feed both of those two
method to generate bar ah-huh so this is
I think the case when you need two
things yes how does the so here you show
that you first come up with like you
know one pair where is right so how does
the programmer realize that that is not
enough so you better try this
thinking these other other method where
you have to generate two things
separately and then feed them together
so also in a demo but the idea is simple
that the programmer doesn't actually
know about the help types what the hell
types are you just wants to generate
some code that provides desired value
and some of those codes maybe one that
has the free variable which which means
a method with multiple arguments and he
looks at this photo says this is the
code that I want but there is a variable
that I need to initialize later and that
involves the synthesizer again
so simply by looking at the codes that
are good candidates he will see oh I see
this is the code and I will need some
stuff later sorry invoke prospector I'll
show you in a second it seems almost
trivial to extend the January search for
these four jungle trees or what everyone
call them where you would just do that
the nested query in yourself why was
that something you do it seemed trivial
but we've been on this path with Jim and
Glenn in the past where we try to learn
specifications that were not change but
trees and then the shortest paths
heuristic which is so important for
ranking breaks down you sort of need to
have the shortest hyper pass and
selecting them is so hard so actually
one of the best things about the virg is
the decomposition that the user much
rather will see the skeleton and it says
that yes this is what I need then
inserted and then sort of build it up
it's a I think you want the life of the
is-3 is just heuristic is one thing that
we couldn't come up with a good one then
just theoretical handling of the problem
that you are dealing not with pass but
it's trees and then just programmer
comprehension it's harder to understand
a code that is a 3 than is a skeleton
but in principle absolutely right it
could be extended and maybe in some
cases will extend it like that if the
confidence that this is the three you
needs bendis party so so it seems like
giving me a program where all these
alternatives that are basically going to
produce the right translation of types
but not necessarily the semantically
correct thing that they hope for it's
just a recipe for introducing a lot of
errors into code because you know the
actual sequence of conversions that you
that you generate may may never be a
real sequence that anyone would want to
do it just happens to be something
that's possible have you thought about
trying to correlate the sequence to
actual sample code in other words I mean
it'd be much easier for a programmer not
to you know select one of these things
from a pulldown menu in which
arbitrariness of sense but to sort of be
taken to a
piece of sample code that does exactly
what they want so they can verify what's
happening by looking at the code as
opposed to just by looking at a
signature are you so we have thought
about it but after doing some
experiments with real humans on real
api's he turned out to be not necessary
and this is why I claimed that after
single generated candidates that are
over calls to the API these candidate
codes actually are like specifications
There s con sizes you may want we are
sort of in the language of the
specification and so just seeing the
sequences often convinces you often
without going to documentation yeah this
does what I need to let me just show you
so what I have you oh so I have a file
name here in a string and I want to
create a bufferedreader and I myself
never remember how to do it so you
invoke prospector the control space and
it gives you these options here ranked
and here is the same except broken down
into two lines rather than nested here
and I couldn't enlarge the phone so I
apologize but if you look at this what
you see that the first to add identical
you create bufferedreader with a string
reader and it's the same except there is
this one extra argument which I don't
know what it does whether you configure
that lightly you look at the next two
lines you create bufferedreader out of a
file reader so immediately see that
these two the contrast between these two
lines actually determines the semantics
of the string it doesn't contain the
content but it contains the file name in
this case and use it as the programmer
see all I want to open a file not open a
string so you select the second
and it's inserted there now you see that
it would be much harder to specify that
the string you have is a file compared
to just selecting from these two options
and also by looking at these two options
I so yeah this is exactly what I want
and now they could cross-validated bit
sample code but in some cases it wasn't
necessary but yes you would really need
some sort of very fire that the intent
is the same but I would argue that this
system would now should never go into
this total sound mixing it's sort of a
synthesizer that the programmer
eventually has a responsibility that
uses is the right way perhaps by reading
the documentation but that zero kind of
bothers me it's like you know do I
choose the one with a zero or not and
you know if I if I don't know what to do
you are I mean no no epic going today
yeah this makes it easier to write code
is incorrect no it doesn't actually just
know so I didn't argue that you
shouldn't you shouldn't check both the 0
is you should read the documentation
I'll do it but at this first level of
approximation you know that this is not
what we need and so now I write that so
you wanna verify the thing is correct
but I don't think it would be by the
standard verification I think it should
be done by better API design in a sense
that when this types match right but how
do we deal jungle if there is this we
just look for the compatibility of Java
types then the code is guaranteed to do
the right thing sort of make the types
richer that we would never plug in
together the jungle is that do a rock
and that can be done with precondition
post conditions and the ideas would
still applies
so I have a question so I think that I
could be wrong here but the end that
argument is probably the buffer size so
we're the zero come on when you have 20
is a default value for an integer are
they okay so you have a bunch of default
values yes so the programmer needs to
know that that 0 could be a wrong
argument yes how do you in your
heuristics first for ranking these
things do you take into account let's
say that something is a reflection API
because now you can create always
something from it from anything by
changing into string and then no create
based on the name right so this is 0 but
at rusev epic emulate for any transfer
so strings are currently excluded as
intermediate types all right now they
can be at the end but not in the middle
because they are so overloaded I did
like objects so now we have a we have a
solution which I probably won't talk
about it is very interesting on how to
refine types by doing mining the corpus
of a client code which sort of gives
types more precise meaning sort of
separating nodes in the graph generating
more precise jungle but the key
heuristic is the length and then some
sort of secondary heuristics are does
the jungle cross many packages and if it
does sort of give it a lower weight but
the ranks seems to be the usual thing
which makes sense because you wouldn't
design an API that takes too many steps
to implement a straightforward task but
still a hero
you know we we should think about this
is where the API design experience so
you know right now if I'm an API
designer how do I think about my job
well I think I'm basically putting this
large bucket of functionality out there
and the document that says what each you
know entry you know so I give out this
list of method signatures right and I
give documentation for each one and then
maybe if I'm really good i write a
tutorial document that gives some more
guided advice about how to use the thing
right but you know what sucks is that so
difficult to consume and it's difficult
to produce like nobody's happy with that
so you know maybe this is a way forward
right so when an API producer is
supposed to do is provide this kind of
guided jungle oide experience so you
know what you're doing is you're
designing not only the setup method
signatures but the set of kind of
intellisense pop-up prompts that lead
you through the API for you know so so
I'm actually explicitly designing this
is the constructor I'm not almost
everybody to call if this isn't going to
work for you here's the next one or the
next two or three that you might want to
think about the have additional
parameters and I'll walk you through
that experience of becoming more
sophisticated they're talking about
better ranking of those candidates and
that's probably necessary but I think
what would be the first thing you would
want to provide with an API that you'll
sort of make the synthesizer more
trustworthy ah better types in the sense
of precondition post conditions to
guarantee that whenever we synthesize a
jungler it's guaranteed to work in a
particular context and I point is that
if you read a tutorial that meant for an
API that is not how to describe right
they don't say first think
your program state is a set of
predicates then find the method whose
precondition you is actually Hollow from
a set of predicates that's true in that
programs that right they're not written
that way they basically say look most of
the time when you want to pop up a
window call this if you for some reason
need a transparent window which is
almost never but if you do call this
other thing right it's a very guided
kind of experience and this jungle oh it
gives you a way of making that more
systematic and not so much based on text
like on websites or documents or
whatever that fella bun perhaps later
summarizing is wud documentation for AP
is he's usually centered by clots the
documentation for class but what john
boyd show is that you actually want
documentation for multiple classes at
once so the cross section should go
across classes like rather than echoes
methods in a clock that's how easy did
you know that this functionality was
also provided by the Tipsy tool then
developed an absurd
okay they didn't have the cool interface
so they lived such synthesis and from
this from having a from type and at one
time Christy boulder and very
it's written up as part of them summer
intern
big reward collection yeah I'd like to
know about that one thing that the sort
of technically more interesting is what
I did not show you and it's
the problem with down costs from the
program analysis point of view this is
again the most novel part that if you
have I'll just state the problem and let
you think about how to solve it imagine
you have a Down car the jungle it looks
like that you have a project out of it
you want to get target sort of making
targets and then you want to from the
targets and get a target of a particular
name and since targets are hash tables
you need to do a Down comes
generics by the way don't solve the
problem quantitatively might be only
fifty percent so the problem with the
solution here is that this is our graph
build out of signatures and you see
there is no path from project to target
because downcast so far have not been
our elementary jungles now we could add
them into the graph but besides the
jungler that we want you would also get
this one which is shorter and it will
throw a downcast exception so how would
you solve the problem well what you
really want this is the badge unglued is
a graph like that where these types are
refined so you'll get a note for a hash
table where vegetables such that when
you call get on it it returns a target
an object the type target and a type for
object so an object its static type
object subject its dynamic type is a
target and then the downcast to target
will succeed so how do we create these
refined types
I don't know if anywhere it would
actually do it so just quickly the
solution is look at the corpus of
clients client code over the APR and
extend the graph that we obtained from
signatures with these snippets because
in example jungle roads so if the piece
of code the client contains the sequence
which is these two calls originating
from project and in the downcast I will
merge it into this graph and now I
obtain a jungler that is legal that
won't throw an exception we sort of
learn from the corpus of client code on
how to use the down costs now there are
of course issues here how do we make
this example jungler that be extracted
and added here not too long and not too
short because one leads to
incompleteness the other one leads to a
lack of soundness
so here is what happens when you get a
larger one you don't get this jungle
here which is what we want it if you
have a shorter one
you can synthesize jungler that on any
hash table you'll do a downcast to
target which is wrong again so the
solution is find the right context to
extract and so thing of this here as
client code which contains this example
in it in this example somewhere else and
we start from downcast and we start
extracting longer and longer chains
until each downcast one donkiz to
property dunkers to target is
distinguished by a different context so
right now they are not distinguished
they are still not distinguished because
they have the same context the same
sequence of calls but if we extract
little bit more of context now we see
that this chain of calls is different
than here so we know that after this
chain of cause in the corpus we were
able to do target downcast to target and
similarly to property and this is the
minimal context that distinguishes them
so this is what we extract and add to
the graph and sort of can argue a good
properties in the sense that we would
like to synthesize only jungle is that
correct in the sense that when the
synthesized mu actually can write good
client code around them one that doesn't
throw down cast exception and we can
achieve this ideal in the limit that is
not so severe limit is infinitely large
it's hard to achieve but there is a lot
of client called other bug free corpus
now this seems severe but the bug free
in this environment means client code in
which at least for some input the API
usage is correct because no client is
correct for all inputs but if there is
one input on which there is a correct
usage we want to use it for synthesis
and just quickly be looted ranking we
can actually in ninety percent of cases
find the desired jungler in top five
candidates so the ranking works
reasonably well we can fix the other
problems then we did the user study we
gave programmers for problems to solve
to wit prospector to weed out and
measure the time it takes them to solve
them and on these four problems
typically prospector led to code that
was written twice as fast and was more
correct to without prospector
programmers often reused code but by are
implementing they fight 500 lines of
code and cut and paste of it so it's a
reuse if you want to call it realz but
often they made errors in reinvent plus
they had bad cause sometimes the code
didn't come compile so prospector always
gave us the right solution so if there
was an empirical argument at least for
better correctness it's on future work
but to summarize so what I've shown you
is sort of two ways of sketching in the
first case there was an implementation
gap and the argument that this program
here is sort of optimization of this
program here functionally identical and
you want to sketch how this should look
like in the second we didn't know what
the spec loss but by sketching the
implementation we got several versions
and by selecting the right one we
quickly could effectively select the
specification as well so there are other
ways how you could use this equation to
perhaps get from here beat a spec into
some outline but that's work that's far
out so that's all I have thank you for
time if you want to talk your ass you
will be here for three days so address
I